Transcriber: H. Duygu Arı
Gözden geçirme: Sara Ozturk
Bir anne, dört yaşındaki kızının
resim çizdiğini görür.
Resmine bakar ve der ki: “Kızım, burada
üç kanatlı melek çizdiğini görüyorum.”
“Hiç üç kanatlı melek olur mu?”
“Sen hiç üç kanatlı melek gördün mü?”
Kızı, annesine döner ve der ki:
“Sen iki kanatlısını gördün mü?”
Ben Duygunur Şahin Arslan.
Çocuklar üç kanatlı, dört kanatlı,
on kanatlı, yüz kanatlı melekler
çizebilsinler diye hayal güçlerini,
meraklarını özgürce ifade edebilsinler
diye yaratıcılık ve düşünme becerileri,
IB PYP üzerine çalışan bir öğretmenim.
Temeli sorgulamaya dayalı
dersimin adı “Yaratıcılık Dersi.”
Ve bir gün kendimi dersimin
adını sorgularken buldum.
12 yıl kadar önceydi.
Okulun koridorunda kollarını açmış,
üzerime doğru hızla
koşan öğrencimi gördüm.
Koştu, koştu ve kocaman sarıldı.
Koşarken de koridor
şu cümleyle yankılandı:
“Yırtıcılık dersi öğretmenim.”
“Yırtıcılık” mı dedi o?
Evet evet, yanlış duymadınız.
Yırtıcılık demişti.
Yüzümde kocaman bir gülümsemeyle
günü bitirirken düşündüm.
Yaratıcılık neydi?
Özgün düşünmek,
çocuk kalabilmek.
Kalıpların dışına çıkmak.
Yani aslında bir nevi kalıpları
yırtmak değil miydi?
O günden sonra resmiyette olmasa da
benim zihnimde dersin adı değişivermişti.
“Yaratıcılık” dersi oldu
“Yırtıcılık” dersi.
Yırtıcılık dersi
öğretmenliğimin on beşinci yılında
kutunun dışında düşünmek,
“Yaratıcılığını özgür bırak.”
demek üzere karşınızdayım.
Yani yırtıcılığınızı özgür bırakın.
“Hayal ettim.”
“Hayalimin önündeki manileri
tespit ettim.”
“Manileri kaldırdığımda hayalim
kendiliğinden gerçekleşti.” diyor
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk.
En son ne zaman hayal kurdunuz?
Hayallerinize engel koymadan,
sınırlamadan, kısıtlamadan.
Yaratıcılık, hayal gücü, merak.
Aslında bunlar bizim özümüzde,
doğamızda var olan süreçler.
Genetik kodlarımızda var olan bir şeyi
ne oluyor da unutuyor
ya da unutturuluyoruz?
Aslında aynı üç kanatlı melek
çizen çocuk gibi.
Zihnimizin aksi
iddia edilmiyorsa yapılabilir.
Bu zihin kalıbının da çalışabilmesi için
psikolojik olarak
güvende ve özgür hissetmeye
ihtiyacımız var.
Bir öğrenci, bir öğretmen ya da herhangi
meslek grubundan bir yetişkin
bulunduğu ortamda kendini
psikolojik olarak güvende hissetmiyorsa
düşüncelerini özgürce ifade
etmekten çekinecektir.
Özgün fikirler üreten, icat yapan,
inovasyon üreten, yenilikçi bir nesil
yetiştirmek istiyorsak
hata yapmaktan korkmayan, hatanın da
öğrenme sürecinin doğal bir sonucu
olduğunu kabul eden
bireyler yetiştirmeliyiz.
Hatalarımdan öğrendiğim anılarımdan
bahsetmek istiyorum şimdi sizlere.
Aslında bu bir kelebek hikayesi.
Yıllar önce dünyanın en büyük
yaratıcı düşünme organizasyonuna
takım hazırlayacağımı öğrendiğimde
çok heyecanlandım.
Bilim, sanat, doğaçlama,
sosyal sorumluluk, mühendislik gibi
kategorilerin olduğu bu yarışma, o
zamana kadar Türkiye’de yeni olduğu için,
ilk seneleri olduğu için
bilgiye ulaşmak çok da kolay değildi.
Hatta çok zordu.
O yüzden ilmek ilmek, emek emek çabaladım.
İlk senemizde öğrencilerimle sanat
kategorisinde çalışmamızı hazırladık.
Çok çalıştık, yarışmaya katıldık.
Jüri değerlendirmeleri sonucunda kendi
kategorimizde Türkiye birincisi olduk.
Amerika’da yapılan dünya finallerine
gittik ve 60 ülkeden on binlerce çocuğun
katıldığı festival tadında bir
yarışmada yerimizi aldık.
Dünya Finalleri, evet.
Knoxville, Amerika,
Tennessee Üniversitesi.
Her şey o kadar büyük,
o kadar renkliydi ki.
Bu büyüklük biraz da beni
korkutuyordu açıkçası.
Dünya finallerinde aynı
Türkiye’de olduğu gibi
öğrencilerim performanslarını sergiledi.
Takım kaptanı olarak puanlarımızı
almak üzere jüri değerlendirme odasına
gittiğimde çok düşük
bir skorla karşılaştım.
Skor cetvelinde maksimum puan ve onun
karşılığında aldığımız puan yazıyordu.
Örneğin puanlarımızdan biri,
20 üzerinden 3′tü.
Diğer puanlarımız da çok yüksek değildi.
20 üzerinden 3,
“Çok az.” diye içimden geçirdim.
Hele ki Türkiye’den Amerika’ya
tam puanla gitmişken.
Değerlendirici her bir
puanı, performansımızı
öyle pozitif, öyle güzel anlattı ki
ve beni ve öğrencilerimi muhteşem
kutladı ki inanamadım.
“Herhalde biz birinciyiz.” diye düşündüm.
Yani en yüksek yirmi üzerinden
üç alınabildi.
Onu da biz aldık.
Ve değerlendirmeden çıkarken
bu düşüncelerle gördüğüm
ilk Türk takım kaptanına,
“Bizim hakkımızda
çok güzel şeyler söylediler.”
“Herhalde dünya birincisi
olacağız.” dedim.
Çünkü ben 100 üzerinden 98 aldığımda,
“O iki puan nereden kırıldı?”
“Neden 100 almadın?” diye hesap sorulan
bir sistemin ürünüydüm.
Sonuçlar mı?
Ne benim takımım ne de bir Türk takımı
o sene derece alamadı.
İlk 50'de bir Türk takımı yoktu.
Aldığım geri bildirimleri, hatta ileri
bildirimleri koydum cebime.
Ve döndük Türkiye'ye.
Bir sonraki sene bilim kategorisine
takım hazırladım.
Yeni bir takım, yeni öğrenciler hem
öğrencilerim hem de benim için yoğun
ve öğrenme dolu bir süreç başlıyordu.
Yarışma günü verilen problem durumunu
çözüp performansımızı sergiledik
ve yarışma sonuçları açıklandı.
İkinci kez Türkiye birincisi olmuştuk.
Yine yeniden Amerika yolu görünmüştü bize.
Artık daha tecrübeliydim.
Amerika’ya gittiğimizde diğer ülke
çocuklarının neler yaptıklarını izledik.
Çalışmalarını takip ettik.
Dekorlarını, problem çözme tekniklerini,
daha birçok şeyi gözlemledik.
Dünya finallerinde jüriden puan
değerlendirmemizi aldığımda
bir önceki seneyle kıyasla ciddi oranda
puanlarımızın arttığını gördüm.
Lakin ne benim takımımda ne de diğer
kategorilerde yine derece yoktu.
Buna karşı bahanemiz
ve sebebimiz de çoktu.
Biz ne yaparsak yapalım olmuyordu.
Çünkü bizi sevmiyorlardı.
Uzun yol olduğu için, okyanus geçtiğimiz
için çok etkileniyorduk
ve bundan dolayı kazanamıyorduk.
Eğitim sistemimiz bu sisteme
hiç uygun değildi.
Yaratıcılıkla ilgisi yoktu
ve bizim hakkımızı yiyorlardı.
Daha birçok sebebimiz,
birçok bahanemiz vardı bizim.
Evet, bir sene daha geçmişti.
Üçüncü senemde bu defa doğaçlama
kategorisine takım hazırlamaya başladım.
Her sene yeni bir kategori,
yeni bir öğrenme süreci.
Yarışma günü performansımızı sergiledik.
Evet, üçüncü kez Türkiye birinciliği
ve bir Amerika macerası daha başlıyordu.
Her defasında hayal kuruyordum,
şampiyon olmayı,
öğrencilerimle o sahneye çıkmayı,
madalya aldığımız anı,
Türk marşının çalındığı o anı
hayal ediyordum.
Neden olmasın diyordum
yani neden olmasın?
Evet, olabilirdi.
Hayallerim vardı, inanıyordum.
Hayallerime inanıp
destekleyenler de vardı, inanmayanlar da.
Beni hayalperest bulanlar da.
“Eğlenmene bak.”
“Dünya birincisi olmak öyle kolay değil.”
“Birinci olacağını falan mı
zannediyorsun?”
gibi cümleler de duyuyordum.
Ve evet, itiraf etmeliyim ki bu toksik
cümlelerden etkileniyorum.
Üçüncü kez aynı yerdeyim.
Tennessee Üniversitesi.
Knoxville, Amerika.
Kapanış seremonisinin yapıldığı, binlerce
çocuğun olduğu bu arena bu defa
eskisi kadar bana büyük
ve korkutucu gelmiyordu.
Alışmıştım.
Heyecanla kapanış seremonisini
ve sonuçları bekliyorduk.
Kapanış seremonisi büyük
bir coşkuyla başladı.
Her kategorinin
ilk on derecesi açıklanıyordu.
Öyle heyecanlıydık ki
sanat, mühendislik derken sıra
bizim de içinde olduğumuz
doğaçlama kategorisine geldi.
İlk 10 derece sırayla ekrana
verilmeye başlandı.
Onuncu takım, dokuzuncu,
sekizinci, yedinci.
Yokuz.
Her yeni derece için
“Ya keşke bizim de ismimiz orada olsa.”
diye geçirdim içimden.
Altıncı, beşinci, dördüncü açıklandı
ve biz yine yokuz.
Sıra ilk üçe geldi.
İlk üç sahneye çıkacak
ve madalyalarını alacak.
Üçüncü açıklandı.
İkinci, yokuz.
Evet, sıra birinciye geldi.
Yani şampiyona ve birinci
açıklandı: Türkiye.
Evet, “Türkiye.” demişlerdi.
“Benim takımım, benim takımım.”
diye ayağa kalktım.
Havalara zıplıyoruz, birbirimize
sarılıyoruz.
O hayal ettiğim sahneye çıkma zamanı
gelmişti ve sahneye çıktık.
Madalyalarımızı aldık.
Elimizde Türk bayrakları.
Bu defa alkışlar Türkiye için.
Çok mükemmel bir an.
Büyülü bir an.
Anlatırken bile o anı hissediyorum şu an.
Tüm “Olmaz, yapamazlar’a.“ rağmen
ilk defa bir Türk takımı
Amerika’da, dünyanın en büyük
yaratıcı düşünme organizasyonunda
şampiyon oldu.
Türkiye’ye bu defa dünya birincisi
olarak dönüyorduk.
Her şey bir hayal ile başladı.
İnanmak, hedef koymak,
çalışmak, takım olmak,
hatalardan öğrenmek.
Yaratıcılığınızı özgür bırakmak
ve gelen dünya birinciliği.
Sonrasında mı?
Sonrasında ben Knoxville’de
World’s Fair Park’a
heykelim dikilene kadar
Amerika’ya gitmeye devam ettim.
“Yaratmanın başlangıcıdır düş gücü.”
“Dilediğinizi düşler,
düşlediğinizi amaçlar,
amaçladığınızı da yaratırsınız
sonunda.” diyor Bernard Shaw.
Biliyor musunuz?
Dünyada hayal kurabilen iki canlı var.
Biri insan, diğeriyse tırtıl.
Tırtılların yapısında hayalci genleri
bulunuyor ve sadece hayalci genlerini
kullanabilen tırtıllar kelebeğe
dönüşebiliyor.
Her tırtıl kelebek olamıyor.
Çünkü kelebek olacak tırtılın,
önce kendi kabuğundan vazgeçmesi,
kendi varlığını gelecekteki
varlığı için eritmesi gerekiyor.
Bir tırtılın kelebek olup olmayacağını
belirleyen de hayalci hücrelerinin sayısı.
Başlarken “Benimki bir kelebek
hikayesi.” dedim.
Bu bir kelebek hikayesi.
Benimki bir kelebek hikayesi.
Kelebek olmak zor.
“Yapamazsın.” diyenler olacak.
Kelebek olmak: Özgürlük, umut.
Kelebek olmak: Kutunun dışında düşünmek.
Değişik kokular, tatlar almak.
Kelebek olmak:
Yaratıcılığını özgür bırakmak.
Yaratıcılık zamanı.
Ben kelebek olmayı seçiyorum.
Peki ya siz?